today's new member of the day is Trevin
plus Trevon thank you I really
appreciate your support also want to say
thanks this john sheehan john sheehan is
today's Hall of Fame longtime sustaining
member of the day John's been with us
for almost five years
Trevon and John thank you if you like
the work that we do if you think that
the work we do is worth just a couple of
pennies for each video that we upload to
YouTube or 30 cents for every hour
podcast that we do it's not a lot of
money go to WWE and pokémon comm select
the membership you can discount the
membership of your choice with the
coupon code this is 20/20 this is to
zero to zero it'll save you 40% it drops
a yearly membership to just 36 dollars
it drops a monthly membership to just
three dollars and sixty cents and it
goes a long way to support the work that
we do it allows us to distribute the
program at no cost to two hundred radio
and television stations it allows us to
make the program available on a dozen or
so platforms at this point free of
charge to everybody who wants it so this
matters this actually makes a difference
ww join pakman.com patreon also
available at patreon.com slash david
pakman show we have a david pakman show
subreddit on reddit it is one of the
biggest subreddits of any progressive
political show approaching 10,000
subscribers and I encourage you to go to
david pakman.com slash read it see what
all the hubbub is about subscribe
participate in the discussion I noticed
this morning when I was looking at the
subreddit
a post about the frequency of the fake
David Pakman quotes a user says hey
moderators you should probably shut down
the fake quote meme maybe some of these
are funny as inside jokes but putting a
bunch of images online associating fake
quotes with David Pakman name and face
isn't much different from actively
spreading this information about his
views I am kind of mixed
this pat will put up a few of the
examples of these fake David quotes for
people to take a look at I agree that it
would be potentially damaging for things
I haven't actually said to be put on
these quote images and sent around the
internet they could be misinterpreted as
things that I actually said but they're
also really really funny and often deal
with the fact that when people call in
to the show we can't hear them or
they're on speakerphone or it sounds
like they're in the middle of a war zone
so I understand the concern Pat but
they're also really really funny and
they do reference some pretty clever
inside jokes including when I say that
we're going to edit out an entire
portion of the show where something
mildly embarrassing happens even though
we do the show as if it's a live show so
we don't actually do that I get the
concern but I think overall it's pretty
damn funny yeah you don't want to see
what actually gets cut out from the show
we're gonna hide that forever I think
it's funny
I think the humor outweighs the
potential for people to think that you
actually said those things so I say
let's keep it going let's keep it going
yeah I like it as well and like you're
pointing out the things that we actually
edit out we would never even joke about
it we just make it disappear and it ends
up not even on the cutting room floor
it ends up in the recycle bin of Pat's
computer and then removed never to be
found again so anyway I get it but I
think it's a pretty funny gag also from
the david pakman show subreddit um
crisis averted Hillary Clinton makes it
official she's not running in 2020 I
never really thought that Hillary
Clinton was going to run in 2020 I know
that there was a brief moment in time
where I think something she said was
asserted to mean that she hadn't made a
decision one way or the other but I
don't know about you Pat it never struck
me as credible that Hillary Clinton was
going to be running again for president
this coming election well the best case
that she has for making another run is
that she won the popular vote in 2016 by
three million votes I would say though
the worst case that she has the thing
that's strongest against her is the fact
that her popularity right now is lower
than Donald Trump's how that is possible
still I have no idea
but definitely a good decision don't run
again yeah I think it's the right
decision I think that Hillary Clinton
running again in 2020 would have created
three or four different layers of issues
the relationship to the DNC would be one
piece even if the DNC has quote reformed
to some degree the fact that there is to
whatever degree you believe the DNC was
favoring Hillary Clinton and I know that
our audience disagrees about what that
degree is but I don't think anybody
could say that there was no degree to
which the DNC favored Hillary Clinton
that's a problem number two there's
always this idea of do you want to run
someone coming off of a loss that's a
question around a bit beto or Roarke
candidacy there are a whole bunch of
different questions around that and the
number three is Pat is pointing out
Hillary Clinton is even less popular now
than she was at the time of the 2016
election based on one poll that I saw a
polls may conflict about that so I think
that this is the right decision I don't
find that this is surprising at all
and the biggest question now that
remains is is Joe Biden going going to
run I see Joe Biden Pat as the kind of
centrist establishment person that would
be similar to Hillary Clinton in terms
of the role he plays within the
Democratic Party but I don't know if you
agree with that I do agree with that and
if Joe Biden decides not to run then I
think camallo Harris would take that
position that would be her the
establishment choice I do think Biden
will run though especially because he's
almost at the top of every poll right
now so in a way it would be silly for
him not to run we will see whether Joe
runs and no more discussions about
Hillary Clinton 2020 she's not running
she said it much to the chagrin or
delight of different people depending on
who you like and what your politics are
she's not running and I think we're
ready to move on join the discussion on
the subreddit at david pakman.com slash
our EDD IT